hi there I'm Jason guts and you're
listening to think again a big fink
podcast since the early days of the
public Internet
big Fink has curated more than 10,000
surprising brain bending significant
ideas and shared them through video text
and social media the think again podcast
remixes this formula surprising me and
my guests with conversation topics we
didn't necessarily come here prepared to
discuss today I am about to die of
literary fan nerd dumb because I'm
sitting here with novelist essayist poet
and as of late note not as of late for
many years apparently a comic book
writer but only recently with an
illustrator other than herself Margaret
Atwood she's also got some really funny
mini comics on her website about bad
interviews so I'm hoping to not to be
the subject of one of those in the
future
she's the Booker Prize winning author of
the blind assassin Oryx and Crake The
Handmaid's Tale and about 40 other
beloved books
her latest hag seed is a complete
reimagining of Shakespeare's The Tempest
welcome to pink again Margaret thank you
so Bob Dylan Nobel laureate what do you
what do you think of that should it have
been Leonard Cohen should it have been a
writer of books well I think right now
at this moment in time it is a little
love letter sent by Sweden to America in
America's hour of need there's a lot of
people in Europe are looking at America
in there and they're saying what are you
doing in this election thing that you're
what what are you doing to yourselves
why are you tearing yourselves apart why
are you dragging yourselves down into
the mud in this way right and we are
just reminding you through Bob Dylan
that you can be better now this is a
person who in the day you know is
singing about more optimism more empathy
more different points of view
right so I think what what this message
is saying is we still have faith in you
America go back to your better selves
because the Swedes love to sing they're
all very musical they learned in the
school and at the end of a dinner party
they will all burst into song is this
actually true
Swedes love to say the Swedes love
saying okay I love to sing
all right because I have yeah like I was
you know saying before we started there
I have a number of friends who are
griping strangely about and sort of
getting in to tell music arguments about
what is literature what is it not taking
the broad view right what are they most
widely-known well-known and beloved
figures in Sweden was the singer song
writer called belmonde okay and bellman
bellman yeah looking up so well so
everybody knows this and for a Swedish
person it would not be a hugely
controversial to say such a person made
a big contribution to the national
literature gotcha
through the singing songwriting so this
is yeah it's not a big stretch there's a
bardic tradition going back back very
far in which absolutely that is
literature you know in literature sure
yeah now then you can argue about the
the details but but the overview I would
say is those two things America you can
be better and we in Sweden have a
tradition in which this is a very
important figure she's a
singer-songwriter is a very important
figure let's get on let's move on to
your book your new book hag seed which
is part of the Hogarth Shakespeare
series in which writers who are known
for other work are rewriting Shakespeare
plays in a way the so yours is based on
the tempest which is a strange play
isn't it it's a very strange part yeah
yeah how did you you know like I mean
yeah yeah maybe you could say a bit more
about what that means to you
it's story so thanks Pierre wrote
plays in which supernatural beings other
than ghosts are figuring okay one of
them is a Midsummer Night's Dream which
uses Oberon and titania and puck as part
of their strangeness but they're mostly
doing comic things and messing up
people's heads
haha and then on messing them at the end
right because it's a comedy
they're like trolls from you know
they're not very world rules well I mean
trolls in the sense of the internet like
they're just kind of oh they're people
you know yeah trolls oh and sometimes by
mistake so Parton puts them magic juice
in the wrong people's eyes and the right
right gonna get all messed up so yes and
and the other one is The Tempest a light
Shakespeare right and frequently in late
Shakespeare he takes motifs that he
carried through to a logical conclusion
such as the revenge motif Ram let his
revenge play it ends with a big pile of
dead bodies including Hamlet's right
doesn't work out so well and does them
over again but has them come out happily
or better so The Tempest is a revenge
play okay that stops its revenge about
3/4 of the way through when he could
easily have killed all of his enemies or
rendered them permanently mad he changes
his mind and he changes his mind through
the underbid intervention of a non human
character called Ariel right
so basically Ariel says you should
really feel sorry for these people
they're suffering so much and
Shakespeare kind of pops out of as a
revenge trance and says oh you think so
oh well yeah maybe I should
maybe I should forgive them yeah and he
forgives them that's interesting so
there are a lot of questions about that
moment too because one of the people he
forgives says nothing for the rest of
the play he doesn't say I'm sorry
Antonio doesn't say I'm your brother he
doesn't say anything he doesn't utter a
cell
so what do we think he's thinking at
that moment I'll get you back later or
I'm really this is the end of me or what
is he thinking we don't know I mean I
think from me what I was also so strange
about the tempest and then let's segue
maybe into how how you've transformed
that in hag seat is that you're calling
it a revenge play and I get that but at
the same time there are so many other
significant plot lines going on and I'm
in Shakespeare a lot of things go on at
once but I did compared to something
like Macbeth or Hamlet where I feel like
the through line is pretty clean here it
seems like you have multiple oh well
absolutely important it's revenge Plus
but it's also three different levels of
power struggle and control right so
Prospero has been deposed from power but
now he's got power over the island right
his enemies have assumed power back in
the non island world and now they lack
power and there's quite a lot of talk
about amongst them about how they would
run this island different were theirs
right right so it is that Machiavellian
to durian conversation that goes on how
should a ruler rule and Prospero was
gotten into the trouble he's gotten into
because he wasn't good as a ruler he was
the Duke but he delegated and he
delegated to Antonio and Antonio then
usurped the power and then at the third
level is Caliban and his two cronies and
they are intent on seizing power by
murdering Prospero after which they're
gonna rape Miranda right and that is
played as a kind of how shall we say
bungling level because they they don't
get they don't carry it off right very
distract wondered they're drunk well let
us add that very low and Trinculo and
Stefano and Caliban by that
results a druggist because they have
found this big vat of liquor on the
shore and they're heavily into it so
they they are a parody of the power
struggle that's going on in the higher
levels of society right so it is about
power but it's also about revenge
so Prospero wants his revenge
Caliban wants his revenge right and in
the middle the enemies of Prospero are
now planning to murder the king of
Naples
you helped Antonio get rid of Prospero
right so that is sort of betrayal at the
next level so he's betrayed his brother
now he's going to betray his ally and
therefore it's that part is going to be
a revenge on the King of Naples for
having participated in the plot against
Prospero in the first place but Prospero
was to become a better than that he
wants Miranda to marry the son of the
king who tossed him over right and if
that happens then all will be well
because Naples and Milan will be friends
Prospero will be back in his proper
places Duke
Miranda's future will be assured and
Antonio will be question mark right so I
think that's about as succinctly like I
wasn't going to ask you to sum up that
plot because it's a very good time up
you know he does not want the help of a
special effects guy Ariel right and
along the way there are some of the best
speeches and Shakespeare of course which
is one reason people love it yeah other
big question mark is this and I put it
to you as a person who lives in New York
in the 21st century here you are about
to get back on the boat with the guy who
tried to murder you and hasn't said a
word after you have forgiven him right
and you have some weapons and your
weapons are your magic books and your
magic stuff and your magic garment and
your magic stuff and your magic helper
called Ariel and without those things
you could never pull any of this
in fact without these things you would
have been murdered some time ago by
Caliban you're about to get back on the
boat you throw away all of those things
would you do that well I'm not Prospero
so Prospero does it so the question is
why and for that we'd have to look to
Prospero I guess I mean no no I threw
the question tell me if you would have
done it I suppose not
I suppose not - I certainly wouldn't
think I would have either yeah I would
not have done it yeah so why doesn't
aspirate why does he do it he must feel
but his new alliance with the King of
Naples is gonna keep him safe that's
what he must think mm-hmm either that or
less likely he's as naive as Antonio
thought he was in the first place yeah
yeah one or the other right yeah right
so so in your retelling you opted for
the first option in a sense you
basically you make it such that the
Prospero who is named Felix Felix right
luck it means yes it means it means of
happiness yeah it means the same thing
as Prospero right okay that he has
enough on his enemies that there's
really there's no way that they can get
to he has the dirt on them yeah you know
you know in in my renditions as Prospero
has the dirt on Antonio and the brother
of the King of Naples he says at this
time I will tell no tales in other words
I could I could if I wanted to and if I
do you're gonna get your head chopped
off right which seems to me also a risky
thing but at that moment of forgiveness
that probably would be counterindicated
to say and by the way your brother was
trying to kill you yeah so so in your in
your story and I won't I don't want to
retell the whole plot I don't want to
give too much away but basically Felix
is the artistic director of a regional
theater in what is the name of that town
cashew against Eric Fox okay and uh it
is not geographically far from
actual festival called the Stratford
sure festive in Ontario in Ontario which
does not yet have a pub called the IMP
and pignut although it has a lot of
similarly named pubs and well I prophesy
that soon it will have a party ought to
have hopefully some enterprising so
Felix basically is the victim of a kind
of power which you know he gets suddenly
kicked out in the way that people are
these days your personal belongings are
in a cardboard box by your car and give
me your security puss
yeah they kick him really
unceremoniously kick him out I bet it's
that seems to me what happens these days
when people get fired yeah I prove it
turn over everything and you're just out
on the street like bang oh pretty
inhuman well they don't want people in
the age of computers they don't want
people messing with corporate brightness
from inside we're downloading all their
emails taking an axe to their computer
that would of course immediately occur
to a person in that position so
basically he's out so oh yeah he's a
stood and then basically a revenge plot
unfolds which involves Shakespeare as an
educational tool in prisons he becomes a
director slash teacher in a prison and I
when he gets a chance then he gets a
chance and in the tempest there's a
character who never appears on stage but
it's very important for the action and
that is auspicious star hmm because in
Shakespeare it's through the actions of
post official star and auspicious star
has brought his enemies within his reach
right and benevolent fortune which they
thought of as being a goddess benevolent
fortune is helping out so auspicious
star and benevolent fortune I telescoped
into one character in my book and her
name is Estelle okay she is a person who
has in
fluence that was helping Felix behind
the scenes because she loves the
literacy through literature program
right right so she's raining Bay Rays of
benevolent influence upon him and she's
wearing
twinkly earrings I hadn't picked that up
that that was a synthesis of them there
well I give her all of the symbols of
those jars those residence she has a the
there were a couple of symbols of
fortune the goddess and one was the
cornucopia and the other was a wheel
okay like Wheel of Fortune so if you
look at her jewelry you'll see it's all
represented it's not very subtle I think
it's kind of kind of anyway it's all
there okay because he wouldn't feel like
some cell knows prospero says you know
if it weren't for the Ovation star you
know now is the time when I have to do
all that's because the auspicious star
has brought my enemies within my reach
right he apparently his magic is limited
in space it can only get out these
people if they're close enough to him so
there was there's one moment I mean
there are a couple of moments that I
found really interesting in the book
there was one moment I wanted to ask you
about it's a moment when the play which
is the revenge plot is about to happen
it's Felix's production of The Tempest
which which is done as a video right and
also an interactive yeah well they've
they've made the video and the
dignitaries think that everybody's
watching this video but his particular
enemies have been delegated to go and
spend time watching it with the actual
inmates and that's when it becomes
unbeknownst to them and much to their
disliking an interactive tempest in
which despite themselves they are forced
to take part so in this moment he felix
is having significant doubts and there's
a important kind of theme in subplot
which i won't go too deep into about his
lost daughter and him sort of not
necessarily being sure of the boundaries
between reality and fiction there but he
says he starts to doubt whether
in the play and his own sanity and he
says Prospero is not crazy
he thinks this I guess or says it allows
himself Prospero is not crazy
Ariel exists people other than Prospero
see him and hear him the enchantments
are real hold on to that trust the play
but is the played trustworthy right I
found that that moment really
interesting and mysterious and rather
than kind of I mean I I could probably
sit and try to write an essay on what I
think that means but I'm curious as to
what you were getting out there with but
is the play trustworthy Oh directors are
always saying trust the play but in a
play is ambiguous and is full of open
doors otherwise known as holes in the
plot right this is the tempest when you
say trust the play what what sort of
quicksand are you actually standing on
right because the the character of
Prospero is quite ambiguous in the in
the text as we have it people have
either done him as a and as an all
benevolent Gandalf figure on the side of
good or they've done him a sort of a
really angry crabby old man right he
then gets turned around about at the
aerial moment there a number of ways of
playing him as Caliban has become more
important in our consciousness he
sometimes played as quite a despot
although what choice does he have if he
lets Caliban out from under the
enchantments of goblins
Caliban is going to murder him so you
could say it's self-defense so how do
you play that character how innocent and
unknowing is Miranda people have edited
the play to make her more so but to do
that you've got to take out a couple of
her speeches in which she seems to be
quite aware of wombs and such like she
seems to have had sex education in
school this is her home schooling and
Prospero says like I've taught you a lot
of things that girls aren't usually
taught so what kinds of things and with
Shakespeare you sometimes think boy he's
deep you know he's really deep this is
so many layers it's so ambiguous but you
could equally say he didn't have a
continuity editor would you well I do
would you allow this in a sitcom
well let me think into that a little bit
I mean this is you know it's arguably
one of his last plays that I wrote by
himself some people say it is the last
one right you know you are someone who
has written over 40 books this is your
we're in speculative territory here but
I'm just wondering like in terms of
what's happened to the way you think
about plotting and character and putting
together a story over all those years
like can you speculate about where
Shakespeare was that I mean dude where
is he losing it or is he know it's
something you'll find this throughout
his plays you think ok we buy this
because we just see it enacted before us
but if it had to go through six layers
of editors they probably would have
pushed him on it you think so there's
not some hidden wisdom we don't know
yeah actually do not know and one of the
things about Shakespeare is you'll never
get him on a talk show he'll never be
able to ask him those questions and that
means that he's infinitely interpretable
because the author will not step out and
say that that isn't what I meant at all
and I just I hate this production done
in a in an abattoir you know I just
think this is the worst possible taste I
do not want it done that way and I
forbid you to do it do that as an author
would you prefer to be in that situation
to having to explain what I prefer yeah
the situation there's a price to be paid
for being like Shakespeare you have to
be dead I could be like Thomas Pynchon
but I didn't start it soon enough
mmm you know if you're gonna be like
Thomas Pynchon him nobody actually knows
who he is or where he's living what he
looks like right you have to start from
the beginning that's right because
otherwise then especially in this day
and age of ferreting out people's secret
identities you will have left enough
clues so that they wouldn't find you
quite quickly or you turn into sand
everyone has an opinion about what a
kooky must be for having disappeared at
the height of his powers or something
yeah and then we get people to him at
the time writing a book about what a
kook kooky was because they actually got
into the inner sanctum right you know he
was a coup what can I say we all we all
grow up on Salinger we loved Salinger
yeah and and in a way it kind of doesn't
matter what a kook a person is right
unless they're kookiness has been fully
embodied in their in their work and if
it's malevolent kookiness then we don't
like it right right yeah in the case of
Salinger I don't think that's no no it
wasn't I think he was probably quite
depressed so we let's move on to the
second part of the show now where we
have as we have sadly limited time where
we go into these surprise clips that I
have no idea what I don't see the
surprise clip all right so I'll start at
the bottom submitted by readers these
are no these are chosen by our video
team who know the archives really well
so this first one Michael Schatz
computational biologist and computer
scientist my interest in cloud computing
relate to kind of this data analysis
data discovery problem of being able to
scan through very large volumes of DNA
sequences a lot of the technologies that
were developed for cloud computing were
actually entirely invented in other
disciplines so in particular large-scale
internet companies like Google and
Facebook and Twitter have developed
these technologies out of necessity
storing data in the cloud opens up a lot
of other challenges in particulars a lot
of privacy concerns about making sure
that that data is is really well guarded
your genome is your has a lot of
information about who you are what sort
of diseases you're susceptible to could
say a lot about your family about your
children by your ancestors you know it's
it's precious information that we that
we definitely don't want to expose
without giving it some consideration so
the concern is is if all of this genetic
information is in the cloud and you're
not careful about how that data is
protected it could leak out
it could accidentally be exposed to
other people and then also if big
archives are made that has collected
many thousands of people this could
suddenly become an attractive target so
today we're a little bit guarded in the
sense of this genetic information is
decentralized in many different labs so
that if there's a breach at one lab it's
relatively localized if everything gets
aggregated together it becomes a little
bit more risky because it becomes a
little bit more attractive as a target
I think these challenges can be overcome
the encryption technologies the
authentication technologies they exist
and there are companies that run with
the highest level of security at Amazon
Cloud and other cloud resources it is it
is certainly possible to do so but we
just got to be so certain that we get it
right on the first try right we don't
want to create this big database that
has all the student and Ike information
and then accidentally leave it
vulnerable we just have to be really
careful about how that's engineer
we can come out into this from any angle
is there is there something in there
that struck you that you'd want to begin
with or shall I I either way well it's
the aggregation of genetic information
basically in how you store it all right
so let's pretend there's a presidential
election of the future going on and that
the contestants DNA is stored somebody
hacks into it and says you know
candidate X comes from a long line of
crazy people and alcoholics I mean it
could really be used against you
although actually come to think of it I
I wonder whether there might be some
sort of egalitarian effect where
everyone if you have everyone's genome
and you're able to really understand
there are skeletons in everyone's closet
yeah but if you're hiring somebody for
instance in them in a corporation and
you have the genetic information of
everybody available you're gonna be
making your choices partly or not yeah
yeah no I guess what I'm saying is very
unfair if you go far enough if you look
closely enough at any genome I wonder
whether you find some horrors you know
madness somewhere in the family
attendance maybe in the family but maybe
not in that particular person right
right right
so that is that would be one of the
hazards one of the pluses is and they
they did a show like this in in England
in which they got a bunch of people in
the room and asked them where they were
from and they all said they were from
England right or someone who said they
were from France and that they had
always been from France and that their
families and so forth and always been
from England or France and then they ran
their genomes and found that they were
related to you know people that they had
claimed to dislike such as Muslims or
maybe they were related to an African
and there were some huggy kissing scenes
in which people in in this study group
found out that they were cousins which
they had never known Wow
so it can be a very me part of human
race type of experience rather than me
always have been a white member of the
clan so so it could have that kind of
benefit that kind of benefit but I think
like all of these like any human
technology we make it's a double-edged
tool and and that goes for actually if I
say triple edge because there's the good
edge the bandage and the stupid edge
that you hadn't even anticipated
III think about that you know in terms
of you like you're an early adopter of
some technologies you have created a
that long pen thing and you have a scale
up and running up and running you want
to see it you go to a website called sin
graph es y and GRA FFI dot-com so for
the audience that's a pen that you can
use remotely like you can control it
solitaire me up Scotty moment Scotty
made Captain Kirk turn into little
pixels and he disappeared from wherever
he was remember that yes it's like
Tinkerbell we actually actually William
Shatner was on is on today's episode yes
pixelated and then he reappeared in
another place right usually the Starship
Enterprise
so this is what the long pin is it's the
first beam me up Scotty moment in which
a thing disappears at its moment of
origin the only whatever you're writing
and reappears and in either physical or
stored digital form somewhere else we
see the handwriting can do that or you
can store all of that and produce if you
need a physical form of it you can have
it later
right and why would you need that
because forensic document examiner's
cannot use digital handwriting they
cannot say whether it's authentic or not
they can do that with physical and the
physical thing that in long pants and
graphi system does is whatever you did
at the originating end it actually
captures the fine motors everything in
precisely everything so to the bigger
the other point here you are also an
environmentalist you care very much
about nature you care about animals you
you write like hear about the
survival of our species because of all
the human beings die there won't be
anymore Shakespeare and yet you are not
right and yet you're not like a room
romanticist in the clay in the Bleak Ian
sense in that your nature you're not
rejecting yeah technology no in fact
some of our fixes are gonna have to come
through technology so yes we've made a
mess
yes nature is inside you you're
breathing it in and out right now and at
a moment when we run out of clean air
with enough oxygen in it drinkable water
and non-toxic food we're basically done
right that's how it's gone us so what
you really don't want to have happen is
to have the oceans die I mean there's a
lot of other things you don't want to
happen to but if I had to make number
one number one a list with numbers if we
do triage yeah we had to do triage yeah
they say don't kill the oceans because
when you kill the oceans you're killing
the oxygen supply source for sixty to
eighty percent of the oxygen we breathe
gotcha
should that disappear you're gonna be
like somebody on the top top of Mount
Everest without an oxygen supply system
and you will get very very stupid and
eventually dies right or we'll have to
rely on some guy from Silicon Valley to
encase us all in a bubble you know what
I don't think we're gonna get there fast
enough doubtless some rich people are
preparing little oxygen bubbles for the
swamps but the rest of us I'm afraid are
gonna be out in the oxygen deprived
window it'll still blow around it'll
just be full of methane right right as
it was before those blue green algae
appeared and changed the atmosphere of
the earth which once upon a time did not
have oxygen in it okay look up the
geology everything I tell you is true
yeah so I think in the interest of time
let's move to the second quit season I
think we'll wind it up with that one um
there are three that they gave us but
one of them is about Trump and I don't
want to talk about it I mean we did that
yeah yeah so let's let's see this this
is Victoria Coates who is kicked a lot
out of them um yeah some form of time
that's not a good answer
art is the best unifying for us we have
that so it's too contentious well let's
see what it says so yeah we want to see
the next one what else have we got
we've got Trump is that it we just got
two more yeah these are the other two
options narcissism and children oh but
it's Alison Gopnik who is a very
interesting person so we can find an
angle here yeah yeah yeah let's do this
Alison Gopnik was on this show she's a
developmental psychologist from
certainly and let's see what she has to
say about Donald Trump narcissism and
children it's all about him right
one of the things that we've discovered
in the science is that children who
already have moral intuitions from the
time they're extremely young
so even 14 month olds will go out of
their way to try to help someone else
who's in trouble and there's even some
evidence that this is true for babies
for infants so the old picture that we
had about moral development was that
children started out being these amoral
egocentric creatures and then they had
to be socialized into being moral or
caring about other people and that view
is sort of exactly the opposite of the
view that we have now there was a column
in the New York Times that said oh you
know someone like like Donald Trump is
like a two-year-old and I was extremely
irritated thought about writing a letter
to say that's a terrible insult to
two-year-olds two-year-olds are not
narcissistic and egocentric and only
concerned with their their own happiness
they have the potential for caring about
other people taking care of them it's
something that happens between being -
and being grown-up that makes the
narcissists and the egotist of the world
develop that's a grown-up condition not
a condition of a two-year-old and as a
parent the challenge is to try to give
children information and encouragement
for those natural tendencies towards
altruism no it has to be said that we
have a lot of evidence that that natural
tendency towards altruism towards
helping for others being empathic to
others caring for others seems to go
hand-in-hand with a tendency to split
people up into an in-group the people
that we're empathic for and take care of
and then an out-group the others and the
others are the ones that we don't have
to take care of and those two things
from an evolutionary perspective even
for a month physiological neuroscience
perspective seem to go hand-in-hand so
the challenge for a parent is to say
give children a sense of encouraging
that sense of belonging and caring about
other people without also having a sense
that you only do that for your group and
you cannot care about the other group
okay so most people who go through being
children are do that in the context of a
large group of people a large well in my
terms a large group of people they go to
preschool they go to kindergarten they
go to school they have a large group of
neighbors and relatives they say a lot
of people and at school they often
encounter pushback bullying exclusion
all those things that we know happen at
school all right I'm kind of a weird
test case because I did grow up in the
woods so I didn't I didn't really have
that much contact of hurt from family
immediately like I had an older brother
that was kind of it and my parents of
course in a very remote no it was a
remote Ottawa's the city it was what a
wall is where a young mr. trudeau is
situated oh it's the locus of mr.
trudeau with her yes it's a shining
shining night to the world showing up
very well by contrast this look on this
picture then on this yeah right he
explained quantum physics to the world
and well I think he was explaining it um
so anyway anyway so yes I was born in
Ottawa but then we were up in the in the
woods so I actually didn't get a lot of
the socialization that happens and the
end group in the out group I just I
didn't I wouldn't have known what an out
group was was it a cult so what happened
then if and well what happened that was
a bit of a culture shock to say why are
people behaving like this why are they
like this I was an overly protective
helpful child huh so I was the kind of
child who would not eat their decorated
the eastern cookie because I didn't want
to make it go on okay I wanted to take
care of it okay this good health so you
had a lot of empathy I had a nurturing a
lot of empathy yeah I think probably too
much too much for my own good but that
by that got kicked out of me later on so
I'm hard as nails now but but I still
have a lot of problems with in-groups
and out-groups you know these people and
those people problems and problems
understanding I do understand
rationally why people do that I don't
quite grasp unless you were terrified
out of your mind I can see why you would
why he would do that and I'm sure that
that's why human beings develop that
capacity no these people will be nice to
you those people won't right so it's
probably part of a survival thing I grew
up in the suburbs of DC and in Maryland
in a very like affluent middle upper
middle-class neighborhood and was
basically brought up with the notion
that three quarters of DC was
uninhabitable because it had black
people in it yeah that you'd be shocked
yeah and and there's an adult young
would you be shot no I mean no I mean as
a young adult I I moved into DC and I
worked in DC and and I literally was
amazed at age 20 or something to drive
around certain notorious neighborhoods
during the daytime and noticed that
people were just going about their
business and not being shot you know and
that was an eye-opener for me I was like
really like what was the purpose of all
that myth-making
you know well I think people it comes
out of people being genuinely scared and
doubtless their parents were telling you
that because they were concerned for
your situation I think a lot of it it
comes out of that that we we want our
children to be protected we we don't
want them when in our day it was you
can't go down into the ravine because
they're bad men
down there right so we never quite knew
what those bad men would do but of
course we exist down to the ravine every
chance we don't don't run those through
the storms they were through the storm
sewer we ran German children will push
the boundaries that way but if children
grow up and mixed communities they don't
have these issues they're likely to have
issues when they find themselves in a
monolithic homogeneous situation where
everybody is of one ilk and they're
likely to look around and say where are
the other people you know it is breaking
my heart that time means we need to end
this because I could be talking to you
for a lot longer on these subjects but
Margaret Atwood thank you so much for
being unthinking in todayI we have to
draw a very abrupt line under it there
I'm sad a pleasure thank you and that's
it for another episode of think again I
hope that all of you are having a
wonderful autumn especially those
unfortunate people who are not blessed
slash cursed with actual seasons like we
are here in New York City and have to
watch the leaves falling only on TV or
in mega in movies I had a random thought
today as I was walking down Lexington
Avenue that I wanted to share with you
which is that until somebody corners
market on objective truth we should
probably table this phrase telling it
like it is
he tells it like it is she tells it like
it is it doesn't really mean anything
does it anyway we're back next week with
new yorker staff writer Jelani Cobb for
a different angle and a different
perspective on the kind of thing that I
was talking about last week with Jody
Pico and a couple of other surprising
conversations with Jelani hope to see
you them
you